Rich Paul has become one of the premier agents in professional sports.
He counts LeBron James as a close friend and client.
The agency he founded, Clutch Sports Group, made deals worth almost $900 million this past
summer for his NBA clients alone.
Paul honed his deal-making instincts as a kid, navigating what he called the hostile streets
of his Cleveland neighborhood.
Today at 42, he's rewriting the playbook for representing pro athletes.
Rich Paul told us he was lucky, and when you hear his story, we think you'll understand
why.
The story will continue in a moment.
So the juice to come to game is when you were younger?
I went one time when I had to sit all the way up at the top and you really couldn't
see the person.
Now?
Now it's now.
You're sitting on the floor.
We joined Rich Paul court side at a Cleveland Cavaliers game last season.
He seemed to know everyone.
And it seemed everyone wanted to know him.
Last year, Paul got Cleveland star Darius Garland, a $200 million deal, the richest in franchise
history.
Garland is one of nearly 200 athletes on Paul's roster.
Who were some of the big names that we would all recognize?
Which sport you want?
I mean, we just had Janet Hertz and Devonte Smith playing Super Bowl for the Philadelphia
Eagles.
And then you got Anthony Davis' and Dre Monde Green's and obviously LeBron.
Do you know the total value of the contract you negotiated?
I would say it's close to $3 billion, I think.
It's more than $4 billion, but it's hard to keep track when you're always on the go.
Showtime, baby.
Before the NBA draft in New York City, we watched him work the phones.
You know, it's draft day, man.
Anything can happen.
Work the room.
Hey, Coach, how you doing?
How you doing?
All right?
And work the angles to move clients like Duke Center, Derek Lively II, up the draft
board.
In college, Lively was known for his defense, but Paul had him work on his three-point shot.
And before the draft, invited teams to see.
Lively shot up to the twelfth pick about 10 spots higher than first projected.
It might not look like it, but Rich Paul is a towering figure in the NBA.
I've always been the smallest guy in the room.
We're in the take the biggest swing.
Some of his biggest swings have been for his biggest client, LeBron James.
Paul negotiated his jumps from Miami to Cleveland to LA, deals that netted James $400 million
and set him up to win two of his four championships.
He told us he works to give players leverage.
Some people say that you're destroying the player loyalty to the teams and the fans.
Player loyalty to what?
If I could be traded in the middle of the night to another team, what I should be is educating
myself to where if this isn't going the way I thought it was supposed to go, I can switch
up.
Right?
We're not in the options.
I have options.
What's the system having money with no options?
It's apparently how superstar Anthony Davis felt in 2018.
The New Orleans Center had a $127 million contract but was tired of losing.
So he fired his agent and hired Rich Paul.
Paul flouted NBA rules by publicly demanding a trade, earning the wrath of fans and a $50,000
fine for Davis.
The drama landed Paul on the cover of Sports Illustrated, which called him the most polarizing
figure in the NBA.
When it was someone that didn't look like me, it was genius.
It was why you get a power agent.
But when it's me, I'm destroying the league.
I mean, those things are absurd.
He got Davis what he wanted, a championship ring, and a deal now worth $270 million.
There's a saying that goes, if you ain't got no haters, you ain't popping.
So you must be popping.
I think I'm popping a little bit, you know.
He was popping a lot at his annual All Star Game Party this past winter in Salt Lake City.
We dropped in and saw a giants of the court mingling with rappers, team owners, and titans
of industry over cocktails and canopies.
Rich Paul had a full plate of business options, one from the president of Gatorade.
While we were chatting with him, Golden State Warrior, Dremon Green, cut in.
The four-time NBA champion cycled through two other agents before signing up with Rich
Paul, who landed him a $100 million contract over the summer.
So then you end up a young black man who's made more money than you can ever imagine,
but you don't know how to live with it.
You don't know what to do with it.
And what does he do?
Most agents treat athletes as if the athlete worked for them.
But there's a multi-billion dollar business going on around most athletes that they don't
understand, but they don't have a rich part of the teacher.
And that's what's special about them.
Paul's improbable journey, the subject of his new memoir out this week, started on the
east side of Cleveland in the early 1980s, just as crack cocaine hit the streets.
When he was about four, he learned his mother Minerva was hooked on crack.
His father, Big Rich, recognized his son's intelligence and kept him close, though they
lived apart.
He owned the neighborhood convenience store.
It's your dad's store, just right in here.
Yeah.
And this was my world.
This now empty corner was a hotbed of activity, legal and illegal.
It was a shootout right here in this corner.
Big Rich taught his son to always think two steps ahead.
He scraped together the money to send him to a Catholic high school away from the neighborhood.
Still, there was no avoiding the streets.
You don't know what you're in.
That's your norm.
That's my norm.
Sardines, Dr. Kahn, that was today's version of Tuna Tartar on the wall.
The door of rooftop.
This was my education, though.
This was my Harvard, my Michigan, my more house.
And the same things I learned on this corner, I take it to the boardroom.
Because the one thing this teaches you that I don't think you can learn from those institutions
is people, characters.
And on these streets, it's no better way to learn character because they're coming
with everything.
His dad taught him another skill, a way to make money if all else fails with a pair of dice.
Paul and his best friend Edward Gibbons were regulars at an open-air casino in the park.
Fifty people crowded around this little area and the energy was high.
It was an arena.
And Rich Paul was a natural.
And how much would you earn?
I mean, a slow day was $1,000.
And not slow day?
You know, four or five.
Four or five thousand dollars.
Yeah.
What year were you 14, 15, 16?
Oh, yeah.
What did you learn from this experience?
You gained a resilience here.
We won majority of the time.
But you also had to learn how to lose.
He suffered his biggest loss when he was 19.
His father died from cancer.
And Paul went all in on the streets, selling marijuana and crack cocaine.
This is the very drug that your mother was hooked on.
The absence of my dad allowed me to take that step
because I would have never done that had he been around.
I had too much respect for him.
If it was not something that I would sit here and glorify.
It almost sounds like you were full-time hustler.
Oh, yeah.
But Jeff Bezos is a hustler.
I think he's not.
Phil Knight was the ultimate hustler.
The difference is they could go with their plan and their business idea and get someone
to believe in them.
It didn't matter what idea I had.
Just no path way to get there.
He found one through a stroke of luck.
At the Akron Canton Airport in 2001, Paul was wearing a throwback jersey like this one
that caught the eye of another traveler.
High school hoop sensation, LeBron James.
What did you see in him?
I began with him, you know, wearing a throwback jersey that I loved.
But as we got to talking about sports, we started evolving and even talking more and
more just about life and about upbringing, about our moms and our communities and stuff
of that nature and it just kind of struck a core.
When James entered the NBA, he hired Rich Paul as a right-hand man.
Paul went on to work for LeBron's agent and watched, listened and learned.
I understand that you would go into meetings with the likes of Warren Buffett.
Being in those rooms is much better to listen than to talk.
If you listen, you might actually learn something and you start to kind of, you know, work your
way on your own.
After just four years, he struck out on his own and launched Clutch Sports Group in 2012,
LeBron James went with him.
When you first started this, you were underestimated.
Not only was I underestimated, I was also not wanted.
I didn't look like the success in our industry, especially from a place of decision-making.
And I wanted to disrupt the industry.
I wanted to be impactful, but I wanted to come from a place of purpose.
In 2013, with his first negotiation as agent for Phoenix Sun's Guard, Eric Bledso, he proved
the naysayers wrong.
He said the Suns had offered $28 million.
And then $48 million.
You turned it down?
Yeah.
But what was on the line?
My career?
Everyone was calling and saying he's crazy.
He don't know what he's doing.
He's inexperienced.
It sounds like you are really comfortable rolling the dice.
I was born a dice roller.
His gamble paid off.
After hanging tough for a year, Clutch got Bledso a $70 million deal.
$42 million more than the Suns' first offer.
Great room.
Today, Clutch has 70 employees with offices in Los Angeles, New York, and Atlanta.
And they've opened the same draft class.
Paul teamed up with Powerhouse Agency, UTA, to expand Clutch's reach.
I had to build a multi-hundred million dollar company to get people to believe in me.
And they're still doubt.
Critics say he's only successful because of his relationship with you.
I mean, is disappointing to hear that.
Would you give him an opportunity?
Yeah, and I don't give people an opportunity much.
And he took way beyond what he even imagined.
Rich Paul now has a new balance signature shoe, a first for an agent.
His partner is more famous than he is.
He's been in a relationship with Adele for two and a half years.
She gave him a shout out at the Grammys.
Oh, God, Rich, he took his hit.
Don't cry.
If you win, you think tonight don't cry.
And here I am crying.
A couple of weeks later at his All-Star Game Party, Paul's friends recognized his achievements.
With a $140,000 watch.
Wow.
Do you have to pinch yourself sometimes?
All the time.
I had it worse than a lot of people.
But I evolved.
I mature, I transition.
How does that feel?
Feels great.
It feels earned.
You know?
It wasn't given for sure.
It was earned, which is good.
I like that.